we got a spooky little show for you
today
first up i do want to give a little
shout out to a very special guest in our
audience her name is chelsea hello
chelsea hi how are you good how are you
good thank you
and her beautiful daughter lila hello hi
um we actually found each other on none
other than instagram live when i was
hosting the cbs sunday night movies for
school of rock crazy right and i said
would you like to come to the show and i
said definitely
and here we are full circle we made it
happen guys
all
it's time for right news your daily
harvest of the good news gourd and with
me at the desk is milo squash blossom
rossi ross matthews oh my god
hi everybody
how about
oh my god that's the best compliment
i've gotten so far today
well the day is still young
first up today we are drinking out of
purple mugs in the spirit of spirit day
it's part of glaad's annual
lgbtq anti-bullying campaign yes
it is
so important to talk about because every
day lgbtq youth face harassment and
bullying simply for being who they are
and today millions are going purple to
show their support and stand united
against bullying and you have our
support every single day and we're happy
to show it so here's to you on spirit
day cheers
cheers
i really really almost burst into tears
when you just said like just being who
you are yeah that is at the core of this
that's exactly what it's about and you
know for too long we didn't talk about
it i grew up without seeing gay people
on television i remember thinking could
i be a grown-up when i was a little kid
because i didn't know what a gay
grown-up looked like so visibility is so
important all right and you are loved
let's get into some news um first up
we're counting down to adele's album 30
about november 19th this is all the rage
we're all talking about it variety
reports that we can get our first listen
on adele one night only it's a two-hour
concert event on cbs on november 14th
congratulations cbs for getting that one
she's set to perform some never before
heard songs oh and then there'll be a
little sit-down interview with a woman
named oprah oh my god so you know we're
gonna get right down into it and i just
have to say that i was really moved i
actually posted on my instagram i do a
thing called sunday buffet where i sort
of take the week of instagram that i saw
and curated and put out my favorite
posts and i
put out a post that she uh was talking
about divorce and the way that she said
it just
made me feel better about myself because
when children are involved it's the most
devastating thing i've ever gone through
and to hear adele going through
something like that it made one person
feel less alone so
i've actually met her what i know
i know
why why are you just telling me this now
well it's this is gonna sound so
name-droppy it's so embarrassing okay my
best friend is cameron diaz but we were
being best friends since we were 14 and
she was a junior model i worked in a
coffee house it wasn't you know we were
just teens
and we've been best friends ever since
but she called me one night and she's
like okay so i'll be over there in like
30 minutes for dinner can i bring
someone and i was like yeah of course
well i was like well who you know and
she was like adele and i was like
okay
and i'm not kidding i got really nervous
and i was like oh god like does my house
look okay
what did you serve adele um you know we
really just sat on the patio and like
broke it down she does real talk and i
loved every second of it like she really
does keep it real so i think this is
going to be a fascinating conversation
from two very important figures who
hopefully will just
you know i know they seem like such
super beings but when we just talk about
what we go through in life hopefully we
can all relate and feel more united
totally and she has been through it we
have all been through it she's talking
about her divorce and singing about it i
can't wait for it and while adele is
writing an album about divorce and pain
other people
they handle it differently some of them
light their wedding dresses on fire
i love this story so much new york
sports reports a woman celebrated her
divorce with a pyrotechnic photo shoot
she reportedly found out that her ex
didn't just cheat on her once or twice
no cheated six times
so she stomped that dress dragged that
dress in the mud doused it with wine and
then lit that
ablaze
she had herself a little
campfire
fueled by her wedding dress drew have
you ever lit fire to anything
to get back inside i haven't but boy
that is ceremonial you know this story
just listen i don't know if you know
this about me but i'm a little
rebellious
yeah we know and so the rebel in me
looked heard this story went like this
[Applause]
but do you know what real revenge is
it's not burning the dress it's selling
the dress and taking yourself to a
weekend in las vegas that is real
revenge
i think that works too
[Music]
you